she'll come in and go mom i lost my
hearing kim kardashian is revealing that
when it comes to her most iconic tv
moments
no one trolls her better than her
daughter northwest
it's a lot in a new clip for thursday's
keeping up with the kardashians
kim explains to scott disick that her
seven-year-old daughter hasn't really
watched the show
but she's definitely reacted to this
hilarious moment from season six
that kim says north has only seen on you
guessed it
tick tock
[Music]
oh my god i'm gonna
[Music]
she sees like it's a popular tick tock
where like they
they do the crying scene from the bora
bora
yeah are pretty much all my crying
scenes so she sees that stuff and she'll
come in and go mom i lost my hearing
son their conversation later takes an
interesting turn when she and scott
who shares three children with kourtney
kardashian realize they'll eventually
have to explain some of their tough
moments on the show someday
at what point do we sit them down and
say like you're allowed to either go
through these seasons and see what like
mom and dad
did all these years kim also admitted
she really doesn't want to tell
north st chicago and psalm about this
i don't really want to explain like who
chris humphries is
that but that is your life that is your
past and at some point
they're gonna be interested in seeing
everything of course
kim is referring to her highly
publicized marriage to former nba player
chris humphries back in 2011
which ended after only 72 days of
marriage
i mean it was really sad
[Applause]
my wife is walking down the aisle
scott then jokes with kim that she
doesn't have as much to worry about as
he does realizing mason penelope and
rayne
might have questions about some of his
most explosive moments on the show
honestly the only person that did bad
[ __ ] on the show was me
stop it
and although he and courtney have had
some tough times with their relationship
on keeping up with the kardashians
scott and courtney have always
prioritized their roles as co-parents
here's what the 37 year old entrepreneur
told et
back in 2019 i mean i think you just
gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day i mean there's
so many different things that can pull
you in different directions and you can
look online and instagram social media
and all these things but
at the end of the day i mean you just
want to be happy you want to be content
you want to be comfortable you want to
love the people you're with